a con TV show and we came that close
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so the shuttle badge show has done it
again and it was a brilliant interview
with Terry matalis the savior of Star
Trek for many people this obnoxious
email to my agent the subject was star
and then the body just said track and he
calls me like what is this something
just get me in I want to go back to Star
Trek um this interview really did show
us the passion the terminalis has for
Star Trek he told us how he was a
Trekkie back when he was a child
watching Star Trek with his family a few
of his favorite episodes and the movies
the movies really did seem to have made
a big impact on him and I wonder how
much of an impact on his entire career
and then the Star Trek movies were
always a part of my Summers whenever
they would come out Star Trek were you
were you a standalone fan in the house
for that for Star Trek or was it no no
that was brought to you tracky my dad my
mother were Star Trek fans why would
Sunday Sunday afternoons were either a
ball game was on or the original series
I think this is a really interesting
point here the Tai matalis is saying
that he was there basically to
co-produce in the second season of
Picard and actually they had a plan that
was going to be way more sci-fi
I would love to know what Tyler matalis
actually meant by that and he seemed to
think that there was some really cool
stuff covered covert happened but even
before covered we went through a few
versions of season two uh Paramount plus
it was there was a far more science
fiction version that we had we really
went down the line on before Paramount
was like
too far
um and had us pull back so there's
there's an ALT version of season two is
that right that was out there yeah a big
problem for me was Star Trek season two
other than there was some logical
problems with the whole you know Borg
problem and
I can't help but think they ruined the
Borg a little bit in Picard season two
although let's do they say at the very
least they weren't used to their maximum
effectiveness
but time mentality is saying that look
there was some stuff obviously there
that was too sci-fi for Paramount it's
Star Trek how can it be two sci-fi but
we'll back away from that but I can't
help but wonder if some of the
weaknesses of Picard season 2 because it
always felt like there was
too many episodes for not enough story
it was three or four episodes of Star
Trek
stretched out over 10 episodes
I can't help but wonder what Paramount
forced Terra matalis and Akiva to remove
the could have actually elevated season
two to something really incredible
we came that close to really brilliant
Star Trek in season two the first
episode is just as good as anything in
Picard season 3 for me it was absolutely
phenomenal I got so excited when that
episode dropped
but then it let us down a little bit as
the season went on I can't help but
wonder if Tyler matalis had actually
just been given the Reigns
and if Paramount hadn't have got
involved
would we have got a much much better
season two of Picard than we got
we'll never know
did Patrick have a say in anything
Patrick has to say and everything yeah
he's the you know the producer and he
and he is Picard so right you're you're
you're definitely pitching it out to
Patrick
calm TV series is a rumor I've heard
quite a few times they're like oh we're
making new stuff I'm like what are you
making they're like we're doing Picard I
was like
put me in coach and they were like we've
we've got people for that and I was like
they're like but we might be doing a
show about Khan I was like oh
um
yeah whatever happens a lot I can't tell
you this was a rumor I've heard more
recently actually that it was something
that was being looked at
um I didn't realize it got anything like
this far to the point of you know being
greenlit of them popping champagne
and actually it was a few years ago so I
thought this was something that was
going on more recently uh it looked like
it was going to go ahead and I remember
as in my last mix for 12 Monkeys In the
finale which I directed and I got a call
and they're like we just heard that ba
is going to make an offer for you to run
a Star Trek show it's going to be this
Con thing I was like go home and
celebrate get champagne I did and then
this phone call comes in like yeah
um they've changed their mind
um they're spending so much on Picard
that they can't do it uh so
uh but we're gonna they'll bring you in
for something and but can't serious to
me is a fascinating idea now if you're a
regular side truck you'll know I don't
like prequels I don't even
I'm not even that Keen on strange new
worlds I wish strange new worlds wasn't
captain pike aboard the Enterprise I
wish it was a different Captain aboard a
different Starship
I think that would have been far more
interesting mainly because they'd have
had the handcuffs removed
they wouldn't have been painting
themselves into a corner because they
wouldn't have to worry about as much at
least what is about to happen in the
next series The Original Series
it does really mean that they're limited
on the places they can go with the story
if they did a different caption a
different Starship they'd have been
Freer to a degree
still limited by the problems of the
prequel
but
a prequel based around a character like
Khan
would have been very interesting because
it would have told a story about
something within the history of the
Federation we don't know that much about
the Eugenics Wars
we do know that he loses obviously from
the outset of the series but you'd have
known that anyway but we could have
fleshed out one of the most popular
characters in Star Trek we could have
actually got to see
a lot of them how those Wars began and
would have got to see them on the end
aboard the Botany Bay now I think that
would have been absolutely fascinating
but there is there's still a possibility
for a Khan Series in the future
well I have been talking to one of the
people I do speak to because when this
rumor came around for me it was nothing
to do with I think what Terry metallis
was talking about this was a rumor that
I heard about plans for a movie in the
future now we know they're planning to
do a movie every two years and but
obviously section 31 Michelle yo is
going to be the first one and that we're
going into Star Trek 2.0 the next phase
of Star Trek
the rumor that I heard and that I
actually didn't believe until I heard
Mary Tyler talking about it here and
it's given me a little bit more
confidence to talk about it openly was
that one of those TV movies was going to
be a con film and the source actually
said he's reasonably confident this is
going to happen
because of two big things and he
actually said look they've already kind
of told us they're going to do this for
two big reasons
character in strange new worlds is there
for a reason
and there is a plan for where her
character is going to be going there is
going to be a lot more Khan involved in
her future and she's already met him in
the third episode of strange new worlds
where her and Kirk went back in time
part of the point of that episode was to
set up according to the source the movie
that will then follow
the point of the episode was to reset
some of the Canon change the time frame
slightly so that it would fit in with
the plan moving forwards because
obviously they did change basically
Khan's age and they have gonna have put
back the um whole Khan Wars basically
the Eugenics Wars they've changed the
time frame that was done very much on
purpose to fit in with what they're
going to do later so it says those are
the two really big indicators that we've
got to say that this is actually part of
the plan and what time metallis is
talking about here is something they've
done with Star Trek a couple of times
before so
the section 31 was supposed to be a TV
series that was the plan when Michelle
yo initially left Star Trek Discovery
she was going to be doing the series now
that changed over about 12 months that
went from a series to a mini series to
the movie plan because of Michelle yeoh
and how popular she came and she just
doesn't have time to do more than the TV
movie
then they came up with this whole idea
of doing the TV movies then they look
back on the series that they planned for
Khan
I'm thinking
that would make a good TV movie
now for me I actually think it is a much
better idea to do it that way because
the story is reasonably limited with
Khan you're not going to get five six
seven seasons out of that unless you
basically started it from when he was
10. I think it's far more interesting
that we get to see one maybe two movies
based around card maybe Khan's character
appears in one of the TV series prequels
in some way that again would be really
interesting
the whole point is so that I think you
can have this far more sharp far more
Punchy storyline if it's based around a
movie around a card rather than a drawn
out 10 episode season maybe three of
them
I think this is a far better idea if
true
so we could be looking forward to a con
movie at some point in the future maybe
in three or four years
that will be worth looking forward to so
the Terry matalis interview on the
shuttlebud show there's a link in the
description to go and check it out it's
a brilliant insight into one of the most
interesting Minds in Star Trek he didn't
give a lot away about Legacy even though
the rumors continue that they are very
keen to do that at some point fitting it
in to the schedule really is the only
problem and well the cost actually
Jonathan Frakes has been talking about
in an interview and to be honest he's
talking about it so excitedly and so
confidently
and Jonathan Frakes really is a big man
within the Star Trek franchise right now
I think it's gonna happen I'd actually
be shocked if it didn't so what can we
look forward to from Star Trek
Star Trek 90210 Star Trek Academy
whether we like it or not
Star Trek section 31 movie another
season of strange new worlds
a con movie and then maybe Star Trek
Legacy with hopefully Terry metallic
show running
we can only hope what do you think about
those plans for the Star Trek future is
that something you're going to be
excited by and is a car and moving
something you're going to be excited by
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
where most of our new videos end up
first and you can watch them for small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you can see them
without the adverts as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]